Hi, I'm Briana from freeCodeCamp.
Let's quick review.
The four basic parts
of a computer are:
the Input–like the mouse
or the keyboard
The Output– what you're
seeing on the monitor
or hearing through
the speakers
the CPU– the
Central Processing Unit
and the Memory.
Now Memory can be short-term
memory called RAM
or longer term memory.
That is usually is a hard drive,
but can also be like
a CD-ROM or Flash Drive
anything like that.
In addition to those
four basic parts,
we have three more things
we're going to discuss today.
The Motherboard, Expansion Cards,
and Power Supply.
The Motherboard is what
connects everything.
While the data is flying
around over here
trying to figure out
where to go,
the Motherboard
helps route it.
So it goes to the
right place.
Expansion cards are
sound cards, video cards,
that kind of thing that
can really up your experience
as a user.
Power supply is
as it sounds–
what gets power
to the computer.
It's usually the part of the
computer that has that fan on
it to keep it from overheating.
So let's do a quick review.
In addition to the
four basic parts of
Input/Output, Central Processing Unit,
and Memory
We usually have a
Motherboard, Expansion Cards,
and a Power Supply.